[Music]
well the chrono buyers lockdowns have
really hurt the country but you know
they've been great for
companies that don't like the country
places like amazon amazon has profited
enormously maybe more than anyone else
from the chronovirus pandemic
small businesses family-owned companies
restaurants especially have been
destroyed
research by the website yelp found that
more than half the restaurants that
temporarily shut down because of
coronavirus
closed for good by july one restaurant
that refused to close is the sunday
river brewing company in nuri maine
the owner of that business rick savage
came on this show in april
to announce that he would remain open in
defiance of the governor of maine janet
mills one of the worst governors
in the country in defiance of her order
watch this
we've had enough of it we're encouraging
all businesses in maine to open up
we should have never been shut down in
the first place we need to open back up
get this summer tourist business going
oh we're going to lose a third of our
restaurants
who knows how many motels and other
businesses so we're advocating for
everybody not just for my restaurant
it's time to go back to work
so that was in april rick savage
openly defied the governor of maine who
was both
incompetent and vicious and she set
about and this is not a governor's role
by the way
but it happened she set out to destroy
his life
not an exaggeration finally janet mills
got that restaurant
his restaurant shut down this week rick
savage joins us tonight with an update
on what he's been through rick thanks so
much
for coming on so you knew you were
taking a risk
in speaking publicly against your
governor it shouldn't be the case in a
free country
but you knew that it was tell us what's
happened since
100 percent tucker since i come on your
show the next day we opened up
they brought in she had the state
troopers in her office at nine o'clock
in the morning
trying to figure out how they could shut
us down she had department heads in her
office trying to figure out how they
could shut us down
we said that we were gonna open up at
four o'clock on facebook we actually
opened up at 11.
they shut up a little bit after four two
health inspectors were the i mean one
health inspector and two liquor
inspectors
they came in shook our hands we walked
them down to the office we were in a
small office six of us
the office is like a six by twelve um we
talked for a few minutes
the health inspector took a health
license which meant now we can't
serve booze because you need a health
license in order to serve alcohol
so yeah we signed the paperwork we were
we were very good with them
and then they left the next day we got
another one
we we got we're up to like 30-something
inspections since i was on your show
the state has been coming right after us
we've been in court
they opened up a court for us the courts
have been shut down she had a court open
up for us
these are court papers right here that
we've been dealing with
just since may 1st we've been clean
we've been open
we've done about 80 to 85 000 people
no cases same people in there every day
the same staff same people sitting at
the bar
we've got let me just let me just
interrupt you there and get and just get
to the science really quick
is there any evidence at all that your
restaurant has been a source of
coronavirus infection is there any
reason to be doing this to you
not at all okay none
not at all no they've been finding me
600 a day for months
to stay open the health inspector that
were in my office
they didn't have masks on they weren't
doing social distancing then from the
same health inspector
she writes a sworn affidavit for the
court that she
witnessed nobody with masks on and not
social distance as they didn't have them
on
they came in several times with no
protection gear on themselves i'm
talking
three or four times for inspections
we've been inspected so much we're the
most inspected restaurant in the state
of maine
we're the only restaurant in the state
of maine that's been in court okay
we're the only restaurant in the state
of maine that they've shut down
we're the only two people my brother and
myself that have a mask mandate from a
judge
that orders me to wear a mask 100 of the
time i'm in my restaurant even if i'm
drinking a cocktail or eating
okay i made a deal we tried to make a
deal yesterday that i would stay out of
my own restaurant
to keep it open for my staff until this
is all over
no they struck it down they imposed a 5
000
a day fine on us starting today the
assistant attorney general
was chuckling when he read the the
the court order she was chuckling she
was like a kid in a candy store like she
just got
what she wanted after months of trying
to put me out of business i'm like are
you kidding me you know i got 65
families that worked there we're coming
into the holidays
and we will take care of our staff we
will definitely take care of our staff
to make sure they're taking care of the
holidays my brother myself don't even
work in that restaurant we got six other
companies we work
other places all the time so they're
singling me out because i called janet
mills out
and we are so broke in the state right
now it's ridiculous
we had a commissioner of alcohol had a
meeting two weeks ago a zoom meeting
he basically said in a zoom meeting he
apologized for being behind and said
he's working on a 39 count
indictment against the sunday river
brewing companies which put them behind
so they're not even doing their own
stuff this is an
instrument of tyranny you're being
punished for speaking out
the media in your state which is utterly
corrupt has taken the side
of your governor who is incompetent um
i've almost never seen anything like
this before you're a brave man rick
savage
i hope you'll come back and tell us how
the story ends
i appreciate it tucker we do have a
gofundme it's maine back to work fun
we raised a hundred thousand dollars we
gave a lot of that back to small
businesses in the state of maine
i wrote the checks out myself personally
and we use the restful lawyers but we
need to
raise some money for some high high
class lawyers to help my lawyer
and and get through this because
honestly it's about the freedom of
people in the state of maine right now
we're in a
a really bad spot right now with the
businesses in the state of maine it's
not going to be good
in another month or two we're going to
lose a lot more businesses it's already
a poor state
rick savage thanks so much thank you
tucker